[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Everybody
enjoy the keynote earlier?
Was it good?
Thumbs up?
Cool, nice.
I didn't get to see it myself,
but I'll watch it tonight.
And keynote, like
all of the sessions,
are also going to be
available on YouTube.
We're trying to do the
sessions to be same day.
So if you miss any sessions
today-- and thank you
for coming to this one.
And if you're missing any of
the others that are going on
at this time, you'll be able to
watch them tonight on YouTube.
So I'm going to be speaking
about the power of geolocation
and speaking about
how here in Google we
think about how location
works, how places work,
and how everything in the
geosphere actually works.
And then I'm going
to be drilling
in onto something called the
Google Maps Geolocation API.
And this API is
something that will
allow you to determine
your location
as a latitude and a
longitude without using GPS.
So as a gratuitous demo, I've
built a little robot here.
His name is Freddy.
And Freddy's a
little, autonomous,
self-driving robot that's--
I've had him driving
around different locations
in San Francisco.
And I'm going to have him
driving around the stage.
And what he does is he
uses the Geolocation API
by sniffing cell tower
signals, sniffing
Wi-Fi signals,
that kind of thing,
to get a location out of it.
Then we'll talk a little bit
about how the data of location
and the data that
you get from location
sensors, such as Freddy, is
turned into intelligence.
And we'll look at some customers
and some innovative things
that they've done, like
this little device, which
is called a Pod.
And this is for pet tracking.
And because it doesn't
have GPS in it,
it's small enough
to fit-- like, I
have a dog who's not much
bigger than Freddy here,
and it's small enough
to fit on his collar
so that I could
geolocate my dog.
So when you start opening
up scenarios beyond GPS
and some of the things
that you can do,
like pet tracking,
and some other stuff
we'll take a look at that's
really innovative and really
fun.
And then some
complimentary services
from the Google Geo APIs,
from the Maps API, as well
as from Cloud and how you can
start thinking about how you
can use your geodata to
really build intelligence
into your business.
But first of all, let's
think about how the world is
organized and how the
world is organized
from a geographic perspective.
Any location on the planet, be
it in the middle of the desert
or the middle of the
ocean, is a location.
And that location
can be measured
by a set of coordinates,
the most common of which
are latitude and longitude.
And latitude and
longitude coordinates
can be sensed
typically by a GPS.
But as I'll be talking
about in this session,
if you don't have
access to a GPS,
you can also sense them in
new and innovative ways,
such as using cellular towers,
using beacons, and using Wi-Fi.
And we'll talk a little
bit about the APIs
that are available for that.
But then beyond
just the location
that has a latitude
and a longitude,
particularly when
civilization comes to a place,
you have addresses.
And in Maps, we
have an Address API
and we have a set of
tools for addresses
so that you can get
your addresses right.
So autocomplete makes for a
really nice user experience.
Think about if you're
building an app.
You're trying to type an
address on a tiny little phone
or you're trying to
do it on the web, that
addresses that are
very, very different
in different countries.
[? Ankar ?] and I have a
session later on today.
We'll be going into a
lot more detail on that.
But some of the things that
are available in the Geo
APIs to make--
if you're building
applications to make managing
addresses a lot more easy.
Then on top of that,
you've got places.
So a place is like
a point of interest.
And at Google, we have
over 100 million places
stored in a database.
And there is a unique
identifier for those places,
which then allows you to
get metadata for that place.
So, for example, each floor
in this convention center
is a place.
And each of those
has a primary key
called the Place ID that
allows you to access metadata
about that place, for example,
opening hours, photos,
things like that.
If the place is a restaurant,
you could get a menu.
You could get photos.
You could get reviews that
people have done when they've
gone into that restaurant.
And [AUDIO OUT] Oh,
has my mic gone out?
With the Places API
as well, you also
get the ability to detect
the place that you're in.
And this is more
than just looking up
a latitude and
longitude and saying
that you're in a particular
point of interest.
It has a lot of
intelligence behind it.
So, for example, the
scenario I always
like to think about
is if I'm standing
in the middle of a
street, and there's
a bus stop 5 meters that way,
and there's a coffee shop
5 meters that way, where am I?
Am I at the bus stop, or
am I at the coffee shop?
Well, what if the coffee
shop closes at 2:00 PM,
and I'm there at 3:00 PM?
Then it's not likely
I'm in the coffee shop.
It's more likely
I'm at the bus stop.
That kind of intelligence
with all the places
is made available to
you as a developer.
And with that kind
of intelligence,
you can start building
and empowering
a lot of new scenarios.
And at 4 o'clock
today, we'll be going
into a lot more detail on that.
There's a session
called [AUDIO OUT]
location intelligence.
And we'll be going into
that in a lot of detail
there and having a
bit of fun with it.
But I'm going to
focus, in this session,
on geolocation and how
you can do geolocation.
Now, why would you
want to geolocate?
Now, there's a number
of reasons why.
Number one, it's most common
to think in terms of GPS,
but what if GPS isn't available?
There are a number of reasons
why it may not be available.
Like if you're in a
big city and there
are a lot of skyscrapers
in that city,
you may not get a clear line
of sight to the satellites
to be able to do GPS location.
Or as sensors for Wi-Fi and
for a cell tower-- like I say,
for something this
small can be built--
get cheaper and
cheaper, and GPS--
unfortunately, they're a larger
circuit and more expensive,
both in battery and cost
to build that, you now
have new options where
you can determine
a location of something.
So I can put something
like this on my pet.
And then from my pet, I
can determine his location
if he ever gets lost because it
would be heartbreaking if you
ever lose your little doggy.
So these are some of the reasons
why you'd want to geolocate.
And when you think about
asset management enterprises,
the asset management industry
is growing to about a $5 billion
industry in the next five years.
And how do we do asset
management at the moment?
It's typically we put a
bar code on every device,
and we scan it in,
and we scan it out.
But we don't actually know
where the device is located.
So cheap circuits,
this guy's built
on a first-generation
Raspberry Pi, which was great
because [AUDIO OUT] But the
newest Raspberry Pi, one just
came out last week which is
the size of a stick of gum.
And it has a built-in Wi-Fi
circuit, and it costs $10.
I actually ordered one
so that I could do it
for this conference, but
it didn't arrive on time,
so I'm stuck with the
older generation, one
that's [AUDIO OUT]
has access to Wi-Fi.
So then you can
scan Wi-Fi signals,
and you can geolocate off
of those Wi-Fi signals.
And the cost of that
is very, very low.
You plug a battery into him.
And we all have those
battery packs that we
can use to reboost our phones.
And a device like
that could potentially
run for a week off
of a simple battery.
So the Google Maps
Geolocation API [AUDIO OUT]
offer to [AUDIO OUT]
for devices where
if you want to scan cell
circuits, if you want to scan
Wi-Fi, and you want to get back
a latitude and a longitude.
So we'll take a look
about how it works.
Like I said, it uses
Wi-Fi and cell signals.
So the Raspberry Pi in
this guy runs Linux.
And if you're using
Linux, there's a command.
There's a shall command
that you can call--
sudo wlan0 dev scan--
something like that.
What you can do, like
in Linux, there's
a simple command where
you can scan for Wi-Fi.
And if you have like a
cell circuit in there,
there's an API that you
can use to scan for cell.
And what that will do is
it'll return a big text block.
And that big text block has a
list of all the Wi-Fi towers
that it--
sorry, all the Wi-Fi access
points that it can see.
And every Wi-Fi access point
has a unique identifier.
You're probably familiar with a
MAC address and a network card.
An access point has a
very similar address.
It's sometimes called a BSSID.
But usually, BSSID
and MAC address
are used interchangeably.
So you can get the BSSIDs of the
Wi-Fi access points around you.
And usually when you
do a scan like that,
you get a signal
strength back as well.
You've probably noticed like
when you open your phone
and you're looking for Wi-Fi
or you open your laptop
and you're looking
for Wi-Fi, there's
a little visualization of the
signal strength, usually one
bar, two bars or three bars.
And that signal
strength actually
comes back as a decibel loss.
And if you know the decibel
loss of the primary signal,
you can start looking
at how you can
calculate the distance between
you and that access points.
And then once you
have all of this data,
then you can call Google and
you can call the Geolocation API
with a simple HTTP call
that you pass it the data,
and I'll show an example
of that in a moment.
But you pass it the data.
You pass it your API key.
And it will return back some
location info and some accuracy
estimation around that.
It's not going to be able to
pinpoint you to the nearest
millimeter, but
what it will do is
it will give you a rough
estimate for, say, I think
you're at this
latitude and longitude,
and you're within
20 meters of it,
or something along those lines.
So it works like this.
So say you have your
device, and what it does
is it scans, like I said,
each of the cell towers
or each of the Wi-Fi
access points around you.
And it figures out
a distance to them
based on the signal strength.
And that can be plugged
into a formula like this.
So this is the freespace
path loss formula.
So what it is is
it's a decibel value.
And you know the decibel
value upon scanning,
because it will
tell you the loss.
So it will be something like
negative-- a really strong
signal is about
negative 30 decibels.
A not great signal
is about minus 60.
If you're below minus
60, you're probably
going to be dropping
off a Wi-Fi.
If you're above minus
30, you're probably
sitting on top of
the access point.
So a good, strong signal is
going to be between negative 30
and negative 60 decibels loss.
So you know that value.
You know that decibel value.
And you know the frequency,
which is F in this formula,
because your Wi-Fi
access point's going
to be operating
on 2.4 gigahertz,
or it's going to be
operating on 5 gigahertz.
And you know K. K is a constant.
And there are a number
of different constants,
but it will give you
32.44 as the constant
you use if you measure
D in kilometers
and if you measure
F in megahertz.
If you change F to gigahertz
or change D to meters,
then that constant would change.
But there's a lookup table
where you can find them.
So in this case, I've been
using 32.44 as the constant.
So I have K. I have
F, and I have dB.
So that will allow
me to calculate
D where D is the distance
between me and that access
point.
Now, what's the
drawback for that?
Anybody know?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
I mean, I know I'm 20 meters
from the access point,
but that's like I'm on a circle
with a radius of 20 meters,
and I could be anywhere.
So how do you think you
could get around that?
AUDIENCE: Triangulate.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Triangulate with a number
of different ones, absolutely.
So let's take a look at
how that would happen.
So here I am with my device.
And it's probably
a little inaccurate
because I'm using a cell
phone that probably has a GPS,
but you'll forgive me.
It's the best
graphic I could find.
So here I am with my device.
And I do a scan, and I see
these three access points.
So from these three
access points,
I can establish a radius that I
am from the first access point.
I can establish a radius that
I am from the second access
point.
And I can establish a radius
that I am from the third access
point.
Now, the overlap of
these three then gives me
a pretty good estimate for where
I am at this moment in time.
Now, this is nice
because if you're
in a location where there
was a lot of access points,
then the area of that overlap
will get smaller and smaller
and smaller.
And as a result, you've
got a better estimate
for your actual location.
And now, there's a few
drawbacks with this.
The eagle-eyed amongst you,
if I go back to the formula,
might have noticed that
it's an FSPL, which
is the FreeSpace Path Loss.
Now, there's rarely free space
between us and access points.
So, for example there,
a 2.4 gigahertz signal,
you know what the biggest
absorber of 2.4 gigahertz
signals are to knock off
your signal strength?
AUDIENCE: Water.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Water, excellent.
Yeah, it's actually water.
And what are you mostly made of?
Right.
So my protip, as
a Googler to you,
is if you have a weak
Wi-Fi signal at home,
ask your family to
lie down on the floor.
And so they'll stop
blocking it and then
you can get great Wi-Fi.
But yeah, a 2.4 gigahertz
access point, water.
So trees also are
made mostly of water
so that that can knock
off the strength of it.
So again, the more
of these access
points you can scan, the better.
And as a result, you
can greatly, greatly
reduce the size of
the red circle here.
OK, so now once you've done
that, this is the theory.
And how does it actually
all work in practice?
So if I'm building
an application
and I scan the access points
near me, then all I have to do
is build a JSON bundle
like this one with a list
of my Wi-Fi access points.
I list the MAC address of the
access point that I've scanned,
and I list the signal
strength of that.
And like I said, the commands,
like in Linux or in Android
or on Windows or
on Mac, when you
issue those commands
to scan Wi-Fi,
they'll give you back this data.
You also list the
signal-to-noise ratio.
You sometimes get that;
you sometimes don't.
If you don't get that, just
fill it in with a zero.
And then you take
this and then you
call the Google API with that.
And here's just an example of
how you do it using a curl.
So you curl.
You give it-- in this case,
I'd store those values
into a JSON file.
And then you pass that with
the content-type set to JSON up
to googleapis.com/g
eolocation/v1/geolocate,
and then you give
it your API key.
And if you've ever done any
Google Maps development,
you'll see there's an
online console where
you can go to get an API key.
And just the API
key is what we use
to know that it's
you that's calling it
and not somebody
else using your key.
And in many cases, some
services are billed,
and you don't want other
people using your service.
So you have an API key for that.
And you just do this
call using the API key,
and you'll get back
something like this.
So in this case, I got back
a latitude and a longitude
and an accuracy value.
And the accuracy
value is in meters.
So when I did this call based
on these two access points,
these were well-known
access points.
I had a nice signal off of them.
And I was able to
get back an accuracy
that it said I was somewhere
about 20 meters from that spot.
So I'm going to do a
little demo, which means
I need to start up the robot.
And he takes a few minutes to
boot up, so just one second.
So he takes a few
minutes to boot up.
So he's got a Linux
operating system onboard,
and that needs to boot up.
And then I use VNC
to shell into him.
Whoa, he's getting a bit fussy.
I use VNC to shell into him.
So while that's
all booting up, I'm
just going to show a
little bit of the code
that he actually uses.
So here he is when I was
building him on my desk
at home with his little friends.
Anybody recognize his friend?
Yeah.
So on him, because
he runs Linux,
I use the programming
language called Python.
And I don't-- anybody
familiar with Python?
Yeah, a lot of hands.
Good.
And Python is a really
fun, interesting language
for doing something
like this because it's
a very low-powered
computer onboard with him.
So running an IDE or
stack kind of thing
would be very, very slow.
But if I build it in
Python, I can literally
shell into him from my laptop.
I can change code on the fly.
I don't need to compile it--
I know Python does kind
of sorter compile--
and then just do some
edits, and off I go.
So in this case, the command at
the top that you can see here--
sudo iw dev wlan0 scan--
is the Linux command that you
use to scan your Wi-Fi access
points.
So at any moment in
time-- and you'll
see what the robot will do
is he will drive around.
And whenever he hits a barrier,
he moves to avoid that barrier.
But at the point that he's
moving to avoid the barrier,
then he does a geolocation call.
And what he's doing
in that case is he's
issuing this command to Linux.
He's getting the
values back from Linux.
And it's a big
text blob from it.
And then it's just as simple
as using regular expressions.
I never thought I would
say that expression,
but it's just as simple as
using a regular expression
to scan for the BSS.
So if you have a Linux box
and you issue that command,
you'll see, in this big bunch
of text, all of the Wi-Fi access
points near you,
including their BSS.
And this is the
regular expression
that you can use to just pluck
that string for the BSS out
of the text blob.
And then all I do
is I just turn--
I create a list of all
my BSSes, and that's
the third line of code.
And then for the signal
and the signal strength
that I mentioned, it's
really important for you
to be able to pass the
signal strength up to Google.
So then that was plugged
into the FSPL formula
that we saw earlier on so
you can get back a location.
The signal strength does
come as part of the return
from a Linux call.
And I just used a regular
expression for that,
create a list out of them.
And now that I have
these two lists,
I can create that JSON
blob that I spoke about.
So when I have that JSON blob,
I can just create a data item
using Python.
And then using the
requests library in Python,
I can post up to the Geolocation
API, pass my API key,
and get a value back.
And then that value is going
to give me my geolocation.
All right, this guy should
be booted up by now,
so let me sign into him.
And I'm going to put him
on the stage over here.
Now you see why the stools
were laid there, so that he
doesn't drive off the edge.
So I'm just opening
up a terminal
so that I can sign into him
and I can get him running.
I've got to put the
mic down for a sec.
And there he goes.
So he starts driving--
oh, he's trying to
go off the stage--
until he sees a barrier.
And then when he sees a barrier,
he'll take a look around.
He does a geolocation
to say, hey,
there was something
interesting here.
So he can do an internal
mapping of where he is.
So at that point, when
he's looking around,
looking left and right--
he doesn't have a backup camera,
so he might back into things.
So when he looks left and
right like that, at that point,
he's making the
call up to Google,
giving the scan of
where he is right now,
the Wi-Fi access points nearby.
And I can do this, and
he gets a little sassy.
Doing a scan of like
where he is right now,
getting a location back, and
then writing it to Firebase.
I'm going to put
him on the floor
down here, let him
drive around for a bit.
And then he would write
his location to Firebase.
And then once it's
in Firebase, now I
can start reading that
data out of Firebase
and plot a map of
where he's been.
Now, one small
drawback in demoing him
in a place like
this, can anybody
think of what it might be?
Sometimes he gets a little
upset and he goes in circles.
Anybody, why do you think I
would get a really bad location
on him being here?
AUDIENCE: Wi-Fi.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Well, the
Wi-Fi is actually really good,
but it's also temporary.
These are temporary
hotspots, Next
'17 has just set up for
these last few days.
So he gets a pretty bad
signal because of that.
So what I did--
and I'll show next--
is I took him in a cab, and
we drove around San Francisco.
And so I did that location
check with him in San Francisco.
And here's some of the
spots that he was actually
able to geolocate himself to.
So if you know San
Francisco pretty well,
you'll see we, right
now, are here--
[INAUDIBLE]
So last night, I had
him scan some locations.
I did not go up this street.
But for some
reason, the accuracy
didn't show the greatest.
It showed me within
a certain distance.
But I've been spending a lot
of time going up and down here,
and I'm staying in a
hotel over here somewhere.
So by putting him in
a car, in this case,
and having him periodically call
the Geolocation API by sniffing
signals around him, by
sniffing, in this case, just
Wi-Fi signals around him, I was
able to get a pretty accurate
lock on where he is.
Pretty cool, right?
Now, what can you start
doing with this kind of data?
You can start turning it
into real intelligence.
In this case, all I did
was I plotted it on a map.
That's kind of nice, but
what if it was a much more
expensive, much
more important asset
than a simple little robot?
What if this was like--
I don't know-- a
$100,000 truck or a truck
carrying a priceless cargo?
Now what if I want to
geolocate that kind of thing?
I could do that, and I
can plot it on a map,
or I could timecode it.
In this case here, you just
saw I put a bunch of pins
on the map.
But what if I time-coded them?
Then you could actually tell
the route that I was taking.
Was I heading north?
Was I heading south?
Where was I in this location?
That kind of thing.
So if it's a really expensive,
really valuable cargo,
I can start doing that kind
of thing by getting a geocode,
getting a lock on
his environment.
And then when I write it to
a database, when I write it
to something like Firebase, it's
really, really simple to do so.
I could also write
that with a time code.
So at some point
when I read it back,
it gets pretty interesting.
Now what if I have
1,000 of these,
and they're spread
all over the world?
Now I can start really
turning data about how they're
being used into intelligence.
Maybe there are some
cities in the world where
I need to have trucks
where I don't have them,
and there's some cities
in the world where
I've got too many trucks.
And I can see the routes
that they're taking
and how they're being used and
things like that, so really,
really start turning
data into intelligence.
And there's one partner of
ours that they have this really
innovative solution.
And I'll show a little bit
more about them in a moment.
But what they do is they put
a sensor into garbage cans.
And here in the US-- like, I
live up in the Seattle area.
And for me, my trash is
collected every Friday morning.
Now, it doesn't matter
if my bin is empty
or if my bin is overflowing.
It's still collected
every Friday morning.
And for example,
during the summer
when it's hot, if the bins
have been filled on Tuesday
and they're not picked
up until Friday,
they can get a
little bit stinky.
So what this company has done
is that they have sensors
that they put into
bins, and these sensors,
when they fill up,
when the bin is full,
it recognizes that it's full.
And the sensor
dials home and says,
I'm a bin at this
location, and I'm full.
So the company, instead
of having a set of trucks
that have to go on fixed routes
in these areas on Monday,
these areas on Tuesday,
what they can do
is, on demand, they can see
the optimum routes to divert
a truck to pick up trash
today so the trash is always
picked up at the time
that the bin is filled.
That's really clever, and
that's really, really cool.
And who would have thought that
being able to put geolocation
in a trash can
could end up being
something that could make
life a little bit better
for everybody?
And I think that situations
like that and innovations
like that are things that
are really, really cool.
And when you start broadening
your mind about what
you can do when you
can geolocate an asset,
you can start coming up
with things like that.
It's not just about
tracking pets.
tracking trucks.
There are 1,000 great solutions
that nobody's thought of yet.
And hopefully, the technology
that we're building
will help you to do that.
So going further, there's
a lot of APIs around geo
that also make scenarios
like this possible.
So you've got the
location of something.
Well, so what?
How'd you get there?
So there's a Distance Matrix
API, and there is a Roads API,
and there's the Geocoding
API and other ones here
that will allow you, for
example, to determine
if I'm at location
A and I need to get
to location B, what's the
optimal way of getting there?
If I'm going right now,
it might be a lot faster
to go on the highway.
But if I'm going
at rush hour, it
might be a lot slower to go
on the highway, scenarios
such as that one.
It doesn't have to be
the situation right now.
You can actually pick a
situation in the future.
And we've put a lot of
machine learning intelligence
into understanding
distance and directions so
that you can calculate optimum
times to get from A to B.
There's the Places API that
I spoke about earlier on.
So I don't know.
Maybe in a scenario like
the missing pet one,
you might realize the missing
pet is in the a store,
or something along those lines.
I don't know.
And hopefully, he's
not being resold.
And one of my personal favorites
is there is a Roads API.
And I think this
one goes really,
really nicely with the Wi-Fi
cell-based geolocation.
Because as I told
you earlier on,
there's an element
of uncertainty.
You get back a latitude
and a longitude
and you get a radius
where you might be.
But if you are
tracking an asset,
for example, a cargo
that's on a truck,
you know that's going
to be driving on a road.
So if the center of that
circle isn't on a road,
with the Roads API,
you can actually
snap to an actual road.
And here's an example of,
like, this is near my house.
And I took Freddy out
for a drive last week.
And if you notice
the black line,
the end points of the line
segments of the black line,
like here and here and up here,
are where geolocation returned
where it thought Freddy was.
Now, I wasn't thankfully driving
in my neighbor's backyard
at this point.
And so what I did was I got all
of those points that were being
plotted, that were
being returned
to me by the Geolocation
API, and I said, look,
I know I'm driving on a road.
Let me pass that
to the Roads API.
And then the Roads API
gave me back the blue line.
And as you can
see, the blue line,
it snapped perfectly
to the actual roads
around my neighborhood,
which I thought
was really, really cool.
But in this case, I
didn't time code anything.
So you don't know if I went
that way and around and up,
or if I went that way, turned,
and went around this way.
So by time-coding
points, you could
make it even more
intelligent, but here,
just being able
to snap to roads.
So instead of just me having fun
driving around my neighborhood,
again, if you have expensive
assets being shipped somewhere,
and these are being geolocated
off of cheap circuits,
you can then start doing
something like this to snap
to roads to get intelligence
about where they are right now,
where they're going,
and things like that.
So then going beyond
this, then thinking
we're here at a
cloud conference,
and there's lots of
great tools for cloud.
And three of these, the first
of them is Cloud Datalab.
So Cloud Datalab is all
about taking in big data
and turning it into
visualizations.
So it's a suite of tools that
will allow you to do that.
So again, if you have
many thousands of sensors
around the world gathering
geolocation data,
you've got big data.
How do you want to slice
and dice that data?
How do you want to turn
that into visualization?
And the Cloud Datalab,
the idea behind that is it
gives you the tools for that.
And then there's the Cloud
Machine Learning APIs.
So again, if you've
got big data and you
want to identify
patterns in that data,
for example, the trash truck
scenario that I was talking
about, you can start
beginning to understand
by training a model to say--
I don't know.
For example, trash
cans in this town
tend to fill up quicker than
trash cans in that town.
Or they fill up quicker
during the summer
than they do in the winter.
Or in the post-Christmas
period, they
tend to fill up really
quickly because everybody's
putting the wrapping paper and
the boxes and things like that.
So those kind of patterns can
emerge from machine learning.
And again, you can start
training your systems
to be far more intelligent,
training them off of geodata
and being able to
build better apps
and build better scenarios, and
maybe build better businesses.
And then the third
one is the Vision API.
And if you were at
the keynote yesterday,
the Vision API is now able to
detect things in video as well
as in photographs.
It can detect
sentiment in video.
And it doesn't show here.
It's hiding behind
Freddy's bow tie,
but he's actually got a
little camera on his front.
And this is like a $10 camera.
And it's 1080p.
So a device like that on a
simple computer with a camera
on, it you could
start recording video.
You can get a geocode location.
You can tag where
that video was filmed.
And then using things
like the Vision API,
you can then even determine
what's in that video
when you're filming it.
Again, lots of great scenarios
to build great businesses on.
And I'm hoping that--
today, I was talking
about the company
that picked up trash,
and that's Enevo and had this
innovative thing for picking up
trash.
What will I be talking
about next year?
Maybe some people here,
listening to these talks,
seeing what's
possible with cloud,
and coming up with
great scenarios.
Maybe even somebody in
this room today or somebody
who was at the keynote
today and yesterday.
And I'd love to hear about
how you're using these APIs
and how you're
building on these APIs
to really, really build
innovative scenarios.
And the CTO of Enevo
gave us this quote,
just really talking about
as the world's population is
increasing and more
waste is being generated,
then it's really
vital to make sure
that waste collection is
as efficient as possible.
And how more
efficient can you get
than actually waste
collection on demand as
opposed to the far
more primitive way
that we have of your trash is
picked up on a particular day?
Then there's the company Pod.
And those are the guys that
make this little device
that I spoke about.
And this device, it
ha a Bluetooth sensor.
It has Wi-Fi.
And it has a 2G cell signal.
So if it's on the pet's collar
and the pet goes missing,
once you ping it, it will dial
home over the 2G cell signal.
And it will also
use the 2G circuit
to sniff towers around
it, sniff Wi-Fi around it.
It will use the BLE to
scan beacons around it.
And it will determine a location
from that and dial home.
And then it will
show up on your app.
And I just got
this the other day.
So my dog isn't with me, but
I've been playing with it.
And if you want to see
some of the locations
that it detected me as being in
because I have it in my pocket,
I can show you on
my phone later.
It's pretty cool.
And again, I've had a dog
now for nearly 10 years.
And I used to go to
RadioShack and the Apple store
and other places like
that all the time to see
if I could get a
locator for my dog
because I don't
want to lose him,
but they were always like almost
the size of a water bottle.
Now, because of this
kind of technology,
they could fit in
something as big as this.
And then the last one
is Doctor on Demand.
And again, using geolocation,
what Doctor on Demand
have done, very, very simple,
but very, very innovative,
is that we all have
primary doctors or GPs.
But how often is it that we
need to talk to our doctor,
but we have to make an
appointment with them?
It's a little bit like
the trash pickup scenario,
that we have to go
according to a schedule.
We have to be able to
fit into something.
But if we need a
doctor on demand,
and there are a
bunch of doctors who
don't have appointments
at this moment in time,
we need to know where they are.
They need to know where we are.
So using geolocation, this
company, Doctor on Demand,
have been able to match
customers with doctors so
that they can be
seen by a doctor
far sooner than if
they had to wait
on an appointment for
a specific doctor.
And particularly in large
health care organizations
where there's a centralized
database of your health care,
it's not like this
doctor is going
to be totally unfamiliar
with your medical record.
You can actually go
see a doctor who's
very familiar with
the medical record,
and you can see them
sooner rather than later.
So again, geolocation opened
up a scenario like this.
And this kind of thing
probably wasn't possible
even three or four,
five years ago.
And the senior software
engineer of that
was saying, a direct
connection between maps,
between geolocation, and
improving patient care.
Now, what better reason
to be able to work
on technology like this--
It inspires me every day; I love
working on this technology--
than to be able to
read a quote like that,
a direct connection
between what you do
and improving care for people,
improving people's lives.
And that's what I'm all about.
And that's what we're trying
to be all about with Google,
trying to be all
about here in Cloud--
improve quality of your life,
give you tools, give you
frameworks, give you APIs that
you can build something that
will improve other
people's lives,
whether it be
tracking their pet,
whether it be picking
up their trash,
whether it be connecting
them with doctors.
So just with that, I just
want to say thank you
for being here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]